42 qui ont déposé un dossier et pour eux
mais nous allons également continuer à
parler sans monsieur alain moyne
bressand monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre votre majorité a
adopté hier le projet de loi de finances
pour 2010 7 et vous venez de présenter
un projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2016 nous nous
n'avons eu de cesse de vous alerter sur
l'insécurité de votre budget basé sur
des prévisions macroéconomiques
résolument optimiste des recettes
surestimé et des dépenses minorés comme
l'a souligné le haut conseil des
finances publiques
mais ce qui rend la situation grave ce
sont toutes les dispositions adoptées
qui pèseront lourdement sur les finances
publiques en 2018 afin de sauver les
apparences de 2017 report de dépenses
avance de recettes
ce sont au total plus de 10 milliards
d'euros de dépenses repoussé de 2017 à
en ayant recours à des crédits d'impôt
wade mesure d' avance de trésorerie
autrement dit on sait d'ores et déjà
qu'il manquera des recettes en 2018
à cela s'ajoutent les dépenses nouvelles
de près de 12 milliards d'euros comme
l'a souligné le président gilles carez
lardoise ou la prochaine majorité
commence à être salée
ce n'est pas anodin que ce budget
laissera des traces sur la crédibilité
de la france d'abord notamment sur la
scène européenne sur les efforts que les
français devront faire en 2018
à cause de votre irresponsabilité
d'aujourd'hui sur l'attractivité de la
france enfin vos débats internes à la
majorité
evo décision pénalise l'économie
française au lieu d'encourager les
entreprises et les investisseurs à venir
en france
la responsabilité d'un gouvernement
c'est de préserver l'avenir du pays
malheureusement ce n'est pas votre
politique allons nous assister au cours
de l'examen du collectif budgétaire
même blocage la protection et kerr
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget et
des comptes publics une sur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député merci de votre question qui va
me permettre de remettre un certain
nombre de choses au point vous avez
évoqué le dépôt du projet de loi de
finances rectificative effectivement que
votre commission a étudié ce matin et
l'avis du haut conseil des finances
publiques sur ce projet de loi de
finances rectificatif j'ai relevé deux
fois le mot réaliste et une fois le mot
atteignable alors que sur la loi de
finances initiale le même conseil avait
dit oh là là ça va être très très très
difficile il n'y a pas de remise en
cause du l'objectif de 3 3% de déficit
au contraire il y aura des visites de
l'état inférieur à l'an sur 2017
nous avons posé un objectif de 2 7% de
déficit avec un objectif de croissance
de 1,5 pour cent il ya un juge de paix
du mois parmi tous ceux qui s'érigent en
juges de paix il y en a un au moins qui
est indépendant de la france c'est la
commission européenne monsieur le député
et kddi la commission européenne elle a
dit à politique inchangée
je dis bien à politique inchangée j'y
reviendrai la france aura un déficit à
la fin de l'année 2010 est de 2 9% alors
oui ce n'est pas 2,7 comme le
gouvernement la firme ses 2,9 en tout
cas c'est moins de 3
mais qu'est ce que j'ai lu récemment de
raison de déclarations
j'ai lu que des candidats à la primaire
et non des moindres disait qu'en 2017
le déficit serait de 4 7% mais c'est
insensé
ou alors ou alors ça cache une volonté
une volonté de les séries et déficits
et puisque vous parlez de la crédibilité
de la france
crédibilité retrouvée eh bien oui la
crédibilité de la france elle se fera
avec cette majorité pour fixer des
objectifs budgétaires
en accord avec nos engagements européens
et c'est parce que fait l'opposition